I know everybody I heard that I see the
chat people are saying Tim you promised
us a civil war not world war three
what's going on with this Nancy Pelosi
and Taiwan stuff so the trip is
confirmed we've got U.S officials in
Taiwanese officials confirming Nancy
Pelosi at least it's expected to be
visiting Taiwan China has been posturing
rather intensely putting out a video
showing their military capabilities and
we even had a Chinese State propagandist
saying outright they would shoot down or
could shoot down Pelosi's plane
particularly if she had a fighter jet
escort so we'll see how much of that is
Bluster many people are wondering why
she's even doing this what's the purpose
well we'll talk all about that we've got
a couple other stories too that are
rather interesting of course we've got
just chaos as it pertains to the economy
and I'm sure that'll come up but we've
got a discussion about the convention of
States a new article has come out
showing conservatives are 15 states away
from calling a Convention of States so I
know when you say where's the Civil War
Tim I I know the big news is Pelosi but
the convention of States they is here
you know maybe they'll lose their minds
over that and then at the same time I
think what's also equally interesting as
well the corporate press is freaking out
that conservatives might actually get a
Convention of states the Democrats are
actually rather close to the National
popular vote interstate compact coming
into play which would effectively create
a popular vote for the presidency so uh
should be interesting nonetheless before
we get started my friends head over to
timcast.com
become a member if you'd like to support
our work and you'll get access to the
exclusive members only show tonight at
11 PM that's usually when they go up we
require a little bit a little bit
earlier and this is the uncensored after
hours show but we also have a couple
other shows up on the website Tales from
the inverted World episode five has come
out and Shane says it is the best one
yet so if you're a fan and you like the
exploration into the Lost Confederate
gold sign up at timcast.com don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel share the show if you
really do like it joining us today to
talk about all of this and more is
Senator Rick Santorum hello how are you
would you like to introduce yourself I'd
be happy to
um I'm Rick Santorum I'm a most
important thing in my life is I'm a
father of uh seven kids and I have one
grandchild and two on the way which is
really exciting for me
um I am a former United States Senator
served uh the Commonwealth of
Pennsylvania for 12 years four years in
the house before that and ran for
president twice
um
I always say you should run for
president seriously I mean you're saying
don't look at me no I mean it's it it's
it's one of the great experiences
anybody's really it's ever run for
president uh it it's a tremendous
experience of learning this country and
understanding how the political process
works and for me as somebody came out of
it who went in there and basically had
no money and was not given any chance
and ended up winning 11 states and
almost winning the nomination uh it it
it should if you put your put your best
into it should renew your faith in
American uh politics but even as far as
you got not everybody could get anywhere
near that I don't know you don't know I
mean look I mean you got a guy who's the
former mayor of South Bend Indiana
almost became yeah you know now is the
number one person for president look you
have no idea how America no one would
have predicted Donald Trump doing what
he did and and so don't
people say oh it's only for the
privilege and only for that it's just
not it you have you have all sorts of
opportunities and you can have a
billionaire like Michael Bloomberg can
get nowhere and you can have someone who
didn't even who didn't even spend a
million dollars on his campaign and won
the Iowa caucuses a lot of that so it
can happen a lot of that Bloomberg money
went to me actually oh good because he
was buying YouTube ads and so all of a
sudden everyone on YouTube was talking
politics was seeing these Bloomberg ads
popping they pop up and they're getting
paid for it so I I I I definitely want
to talk to you about your time you know
in the Senate and all that stuff too so
thanks for thanks for joining us sure we
also have Mark meckler good to be with
you so my background is legal I was a
lawyer for most of my professional
career uh ended up stumbling into
politics during the days of the Tea
Party founded the largest tea party
organization in the nation ultimately 23
million people sort of changed the
political landscape and then I bailed on
it because it became part of Washington
DC I watched it get co-opted you have
the biggest swing election in the
history of America since 1938 takes
place in 2010
literally by 2012 most of the folks that
were elected had been eaten by the swamp
I was getting ready to leave and I had a
friend who said he can't quit politics I
said yes I can I go back to my chickens
I'm a chicken guy too yeah so we're
living out in the country and he said
look we can't give up the problem in
politics really isn't the people that
we're electing or not electing the
problem is we broke the structure of
government and if you want to repair the
structure there's a constitutional
method for doing so found in Article
Five that's what we're doing trying to
call a Convention of states to propose
amendments to take power away from DC
and give it back to the people that's
what I spend my time doing now I've been
in 48 states in the last couple of years
I've just on the ground with Grassroots
all over the country like Senator
Santorum I love the American people I
have faith in the people just not in the
government anymore I dig it I like the
idea there's there's some pros and
there's console but we'll get into all
that stuff we're also hanging out with
Hannah Claire hi I'm a writer for
timcast.com my name is Hannah Claire
brimlow I'm filling in for Ian who is
away I have no facts about gems for you
I wish I did yeah or graphene yeah I Tim
had to explain to me what graphene was I
really feel like somewhere along the
line the American Science
uh do you have a bottle of graphene
sitting right there though so it's very
impressive a patent-pending product is
sitting next to me it makes me nervous I
don't know if it's gonna catch on fire
and Lydia's on vacation so joining us
handling all the camera work is Chris
there you go all right let's jump into
this first story we got this from
Politico Pelosi Taiwan trip overrides
Chinese military threats military and
diplomatic efforts limit Beijing to
angry Bluster I mean simply put we only
need the first opening paragraph here
house Speaker Nancy Pelosi will visit
Taiwan on Tuesday decisively ending
weeks of wrangling between the United
States and China about whether she
should make the trip Pelosi's
controversial stop in Taipei which would
make her the highest ranking U.S
official to visit the self-governing
island in decades indicates the Pentagon
has downgraded its assessment of a
potential credible Chinese military
threat to the speaker's safety Beijing
has strongly protested Pelosi's Taiwan
visit and issued lurid warnings of a
Stern Chinese response quote a visit to
Taiwan by her would constitute a gross
interference in China's Internal Affairs
and lead to a very serious situation and
Grave consequences Chinese foreign
Ministry spokesperson Zhao at Legion
said Monday
I don't I'm assuming you guys saw as
well you had that guy from Global times
basically say well shoot her plane down
so I'm wondering I got a couple
questions why do you think she's going
is the threat really is there really a
threat or is the World War III stuff
just people posting it because it gets
clicks
well once she announced she was going
she had to go because when China reacted
the way they did uh the speaker of the
third ranking person on our government
the speaker and the United States can't
can't be bullied to going to a uh an
Allied country because of China China is
the is the big threat to our to our
country it will be for uh for My
Lifetime and probably a lifetime of
everybody listening to this podcast uh
China's a serious player we don't take
them as seriously as we should and and
uh and I'm very happy to I'm very I
don't agree with Nancy Pelosi on
anything but I I agreed that she should
go to Taiwan I'm glad she's going into
white why I don't know why she's going
but I'm glad she is and I'm I'm glad she
stood up to the Chinese and is going
tomorrow yeah what do you think Mark
yeah you know I get a lot of fundraising
texts from politicians on both sides of
the aisle it's a great fundraising Ploy
for Nancy Pelosi I mean really you're
going to see texts about this about how
she's saving the Free World and so I
think part is a political play and she's
trying to set herself aside from the
Biden Administration they're going to
get their backsides handed to them in
this election and I think she wants to
be able to blame Biden and separate
herself from that really I'm is she
she's running for reelection she's going
to keep going how old is she she's 83.
man she's already been she's been
embalmed already so she can go for a
long time she's older than I thought she
was I thought she was just shy of 80.
she's 83. I think I could be right yeah
I think that's correct I think that's
right yeah I mean crazy old I think
there's a problem we have in our
government in general that people just
serve literally until they pass away and
it's never the way it was intended to be
I think this is one of the fundamental
problems in our country I'm worried
about military conflict especially with
China and I wonder why it is because you
know Rick you mentioned China's the big
threat I think I agree absolutely why is
it Russia 24 7 on corporate press
mainstream media Democrats even a bunch
of Republicans just scream Rush all day
well because Russia attacked Ukraine I
mean no one was screaming Russia
Trump and Russia and the Russian
collusion in Russia because of Russian
collusion but they weren't they weren't
concerned about Russia as a great threat
to to the country that China is the
great threat and and candidly we made
China the great threat we we had a
policy which by the way I I was
supportive of and and thought at the
time it was a viable policy which was to
try to engage China try to bring China
in the 20 21st century and uh and you
know build up capitalism within China
and markets and and that that would move
China toward uh a a more peaceful and
Free World all we've done is uh arm arm
them with many more resources than they
would have ever had have they stuck in
their uh old pre-market days and made
them a real threat uh we have to we have
to start acting differently that's a
whole other discussion but we're not
doing enough to confront China right now
do you regret you are positioning yeah
well do I regret it it's
was it a was it a good idea was it a
viable option it hadn't been tried
before and and you can say well we tried
it it didn't work was I I hate going
back and said well you know I it was a
bad idea well no it was actually an
interesting idea it could it have worked
maybe with a different leader in China
maybe with different I don't know but it
didn't work you know I think we just
have to recognize it didn't work there's
a long-term misunderstanding of
Americans of culture internationally I
think we're very ethnocentric with a
western cultural view the idea that you
were going to take a country with a 3
000 year history and change their view
of themselves in the world you know they
call themselves the one son there's only
one son in the galaxy and that's China
they've always believed that and so I
think it's just and I think we do this
I'm not pointing at you in particular
but I think we do this as a nation that
we look at other countries and we think
oh they have the same aspirations as we
do you know they want to be part of the
world Community it was never China's
aspiration I'm not saying I understood
this back then I'm saying in hindsight
and I think we need to look at the world
more realistically where are they
actually coming from what's their
history what do they really want now not
what can we do what will they do if
we're nice to them which tends to be our
foreign policy I I the only the only
thing I would say is we have to look at
it in the context of when this happened
this was basically the 19 late late 80s
and 90s and the Soviet Union had fallen
the the the Iron Curtain had fallen and
so we we were feeling feeling our oats
yes that in fact we can affect the
course of geopolitics if you remember we
books are written the end of History
right democracy and capitalism that was
going to be it and and that was Hubris
but if you look at what how things had
gone thanks to Reagan and others who
stood up against the Soviets and and and
did infiltrate them with a lot of
information about free speech and
capitalism you can make the argument it
sort of worked now what's happened since
then has been a cluster but it is it's a
it's it was not an irrational thing to
contemplate at the time I think it's the
inverse I think you had a lot of special
interests in United States that thought
you know we could democratize China we
could you know bring Capitals in there
and said what's that what's ended up
happening is the weird authoritarian
communist woke stuff has been seeping
into our side of things our movies are
being edited to placate China not the
other way around
yeah and I think look there's a there's
a military power raw military power what
they do in South China Sea the economic
power and their understanding of
economic leverage has been extraordinary
the amount of Chinese money that's
flowed into this country it's not that
hard to buy most people I hate to say
that but when when you go to somebody
and it's here's a few million dollars
and people never been able to imagine
that kind of money and all you have to
do is be nice about China censor some
stuff about China people do it do you
know the stories about how the Chinese
would manipulate pows or you know what
they would do is
they would say something like if you
want to eat today you need to tell us
one thing that you think is wrong with
with America or something of that effect
like whatever country they were from and
they would say something like uh we've
got a homelessness problem right of
course America's not perfect but it's
one small step at a time that's the
psychological manipulation and I feel
like we're experiencing that on a grand
scale I don't know you know we've had
we've had guests here who are
researchers on China
who tell us that we know about what do
they call the 50-cent Army are you guys
familiar with that no that uh citizens
of China or people like who who work in
propaganda get paid 50 cents every time
they post something Pro China or
disparaging about its enemies so you go
on social media and what happens you go
on Twitter you go on YouTube for
instance and you say bad things they
flag you they Mass flag you they report
you you go on Twitter all of a sudden
you're being inundated ratio with people
being like you're you're wrong and you
don't understand they have these people
attempting to manipulate public opinion
I think I think we had a lot of
politicians who really really
underestimated the future of what
Warfare was going to be like yeah we're
you you see you you took the words out
of my mouth we were at war with China
and and I know that people say oh yeah
War monger and warmonger no no I'm not
saying that we're in fact the problem is
we're not at war with China we're not
treating China the way they're treating
us the the the Espionage that goes on
here that the stealing of technology I
mean it's just it is incredible how much
of of American created Ingenuity has
been ex expropriated to China and and
yet we allow
thousands maybe Millions I don't know of
Chinese to come here to go and get
educated here in our countries and and
and and bring all that technology yeah
oh man it's it's we we have to sort of
take a step back and say why are we
letting people come into this country
who are here to steal technology to be
educated to come turn around and then
use it against it so again we aren't on
a war footing when it comes to China we
would never during uh any pick another
period of history when when someone was
attacking us we would never allow them
to come and and have positions of of
power and authority and education and
and use it to hurt us and we do with
China and you're and I think again you
hit the point a lot of it is money I
mean the fact is these universities
need these students and want these
students because they pay cash it's also
true of private independent boarding
schools if you look at the ratio of
international students when a school is
about to go under they start really
opening the doors to International
specifically usually it's China and
Korea because their families have the
money to pay tuition they don't have to
offer scholarships I feel like in my
lifetime we've always had sort of been
on our back foot with China and I
increasingly I agree it's definitely the
economic uh Chokehold that they have on
us I mean when the White House announced
they were going to boycott the Olympics
this year it was like well we're going
to diplomatically boy what's going on
with the uyghurs is really bad so we're
not going to send Biden but also
athletes don't take your phones because
they will be hacking them it's just
routine like we took this very strange
like just boycott just don't go don't
send anyone and that is definitely a
tragedy for a lot of athletes who've
worked really hard for that but we just
always placate China we don't take this
cohesive stance we always sort of say
well we're we're sort of we're sort of
against that what we don't know and I
think it's just it's so strange it's the
worst part of American foreign policy
for me because we're economically
dependent upon them so this is the
reality look I just got to say it I mean
this is a lot of what we're talking
about is indicative of some kind of
Western or or U.S cultural or
governmental collapse absolutely that's
why I think a Convention of States we've
already got people who are chatting
saying like they think it's a bad idea
for a variety of reasons which we'll
definitely get into in a bit but what I
want to say is when you take a look at
what's going on with China what do they
have they have a strong authoritarian
structure a a a
monoculture that is the CCP the Chinese
Communist party people like to often
point out like we're not talking about
the Chinese people we're talking about
their government and I'm like yeah look
I I think I think colloquially it's
understood we're talking about their
government the strangle or the
government hold the government has the
suppression of information they have we
don't have that in the United States to
a certain degree we do obviously big
Tech censorship the corporate propaganda
press will will run lies but this show
exists so we're clearly better than
China but that's also as much of it as
as much as it is a strength it's a it's
something they exploit they know there
are people in this country that they can
pay who will say whatever needs to be
said because we don't have a cohesive
shared culture anymore it used to be we
were talking about this last week with
the fall of Empires I think zubi was
bringing this up that when you no longer
have the idea of like God in country I
don't mean that literally got in country
I mean like this idea of like this is
our country this is what we believe this
is what we share this our experience
when you don't have that anymore your
country can be gutted ripped apart and
that precipitates the collapse so now I
see what's happening with China they're
absolutely exploiting our political
divisions how much longer can we last
when you have the Thousand talents
program China goes in and they pay
professors to to give up our research
where you've got stories about Chinese
Nationals ferrying viruses and vials
getting caught and arrested there's
there's no respect for this country and
the problem is we don't have a unified
culture of a culture War which means
they can keep just chipping away at the
crack until the rock splits well that's
the intent the culture wars at least
partially being fostered by the Chinese
it's part of the reason they censor our
culture I have a young friend who's on
the UC Berkeley campus and one of the
most liberal campuses in the country
she's half ethnic Chinese her mom was
ethnic Chinese she was raised in her
family to hate America she was raised to
believe that this is a vile terrible
place that Americans are not to be
trusted and that eventually China would
Prevail and China specifically meaning
the CCP that's on a mainstream college
campus that culture that idea is
supported she said the majority of the
Chinese that she knew on campus believed
this you know she's welcome to walk in
those communities because of her partial
ethnic Chinese background and she said
it's just horrendous it's totally
anti-American and it is at the Forefront
of culture on our college campuses all
across the country how long how long can
something like this go on for especially
you know when I look at Pelosi going to
Taiwan my question is you know for what
purpose does it serve like you were
saying just a moment ago that's a lot of
what people are asking is it a
distraction is it the Democrats are
failing so miserably that she's like
well this will shake up the news cycle
and get us get get us off the recession
maybe the idea is like wartime
presidents do well maybe if I go there
and confront China on something it'll be
good for the Democratic Party
yeah to me it seems like a distraction I
mean it's a it's an excellent political
distraction they've got no good news
that the Democratic party can run on
right the economy is a shamble our
Industries are falling apart are
standing in the International Community
is at an all-time low their own base
despises them basically at this point if
you look at the numbers among Hispanics
we've never seen anything like this in
in the modern history of the country 24
approval rating for Biden among
Hispanics lower than among whites I mean
it's really extraordinary so she needs
to do something she needs to roll some
kind of political hand grenade in the
room to try to distract yeah I've I've
taken the approach throughout my time in
politics when someone does something
that I think is good for the country
even though they may be doing it for the
wrong reason I commend them for doing it
and and so I'm not going to say anything
negative about Nancy Pelosi going there
because I think it's it's the right
thing to do the fact that the by
demonstration did not want her to go and
it was very clear they didn't want her
to go because they were afraid of
China's reaction and she stood up to
them and said and obviously said she was
going uh again there may be there may be
politics behind there may like everybody
does everything
I have I don't know I have no idea it
makes no sense to me why she's doing it
other than
she under maybe she understands I I
don't I can't understand how people
don't understand how big a threat China
is and how important this conflict is
and look we tend to think of everybody
on the other side it's just horrible
terrible on everything and they don't
care about America anyway
it I I look I serve with these people
and and I think ninety percent of the
time that's true but there are people
that uh that do care about the security
of our country and understand that China
is a threat on the other side of the
aisle maybe she's one of them again I
may be giving her more credit than she
deserves but I'm willing to give her the
benefit of that because she's doing the
right thing I I respect her going to
Taiwan
um but I question it obviously and it
it's like I really don't like her as as
a person everything she represents the
elitism of of politics I think she's a
bad person I think she's manipulative I
think she's overly emotional I think she
and and her cohorts traded Untold
problems United States during the Trump
years with the obsession over Russia and
the lies they espoused and I think it's
it's oh that's true right well that's
true but I do you know respect to going
to Taiwan I guess
but look I know her I served with her I
spent I spent time I know Nancy I mean
we're not buddies but uh and so this is
a real head scratcher for me uh but
yeah give her no look thinking about the
current state of the culture war and you
know I'm thinking about we've got the
you know the first time into the show
we're like World War III China what's
happening and now it's like uh Civil War
are we heading in that direction can
people trust the politicians we've got
people in the chat who are saying you're
a rhino right but you're it's me that
Republican name only that's me um
obviously nobody and I bet you they've
been involved in politics and have
worked on conservative causes for 40
years just like I have I'm bet I'm a
rhino right oh yeah this I mean this is
the problem I have yeah if so many
people come up to me who have been a
conservative for 20 minutes and and they
say oh this guy's a rhino yeah this
guy's a rhino who if you if you Google
my name to see what kind of rhino I am
that I've been I've been ostracized for
the last 20 years for standing up for
for cultural truths and for standing up
for uh a you know free markets and look
I I I I respect everybody can have their
opinion on things and one of the things
that I I realized is you just go do the
right thing and don't worry about what
other people say about you and and so
I'm I'm out here right now where I'm I'm
teaming up with another guy who's called
a rhino on occasion right because among
other things among other things for uh
for standing up for the the ultimate in
our constitutional freedoms which is
federalism uh the idea that America
will end up candidly in a civil war if
we don't begin to respect that people in
some areas of the states are going to
live their lives differently than people
in other areas of the states and by the
way that was the case from the very
beginning that's what our Founders
understood could hold a country together
as big and diverse even at that point we
were talking about 13 colonies but they
saw the vastness of the United of what
could be the United States and they
realized over a country of this size
you're going to have people who are
going to behave and want different
Lifestyles people who are going to live
in the mountains are not going to be the
same as people are going to live in the
cities and and the idea that that we're
going to have a central government
that's powerful that's going to make
everybody have the same ideas and
philosophies and not give local control
and freedom to to States and communities
and families to live their lives the way
they want they realize that that was a
loser and and so federalism was the
approach and that's what we're trying to
restore through this process Rhode
Island Rogue island is basically a city
yeah that has two senators that should
have lost a seat in Congress during the
last census but they messed up oh wow
really wow I just think it's funny when
the Democrats come out and they're like
why do why does Wyoming get you know two
senators I'm like why does Rhode Island
it's like I understand
yeah right Delaware and as is only a
tiny bit bigger you know so I I gotta
tell you man I don't envy you know you
being in politics people are always
mentioning like will you ever consider
politics and I'm like no never there's
no way to represent everybody and that's
exactly what the beautiful father look I
I don't I think that it's a it's a
ridiculous idea that you're going to
represent everybody but you got to be
you have to be mentally ill to be to be
able to represent everybody this such
diversity in this country I I've always
people have always said you know how did
you do it how did you how did you uh you
know go to Washington and because I
always felt like my duty was to do what
gather as much information as I could
look at the context of which everything
was done and make the best decision and
then make your case as to why you know
why why why it's right for America and
not worry about the Electoral
consequence because you can't you can't
just go out and and jump for whatever
the poll says from one time another look
there's there's there's truth I believe
in it I believe there is a truth and I
believe that that uh our Founders put
together a process that uh in our
Constitution that works and you just
follow those those two things the truth
and the and and aligning with the
Constitution you'll be fine yeah you
know I look at
we we often will talk about here who's
right in the culture War the left or the
right what does left and right even mean
right I grew up liberal and here I am
being called right wing because one
simple reason I know what's going on in
the media so a really great example or I
was going I know what's going on in
politics really good examples we had a
guest on the show who claimed I said Joe
Biden said if you want the billion
dollars you gotta fire the prosecutor
and he said looked at me smart and said
that never happened
and then I pulled up the video and
played it for him and he was shocked
this is what makes you right wing these
days that if you show a video in the
news that people are talking about they
don't know why because CNN's lying
because MSNBC is lying on occasion Fox
News even so when you've got here's what
I see it's the rule for the Democrats
that they are misleading you it is the
exception with Republicans that they're
misleading you there are a lot of bad
Republicans they're often misleading you
but there's a handful of really good
ones on the Democrat side I we had Tulsi
gabbard I thought was being honest I
didn't agree with some of our political
positions look what happened to her now
she's the one on Fox news now she's
she's all right now I know because when
when you talk about what's true that
clearly makes you right wing even if
your political positions how do we
Salvage I hate to say it this country
how do we how do we save it when you've
got people who believe
media lies that the media can just make
something up
claim you're the one making it up and
the example I always give these are the
people who believe Jesse Smith these are
the people who chase after the Russia
gate narrative for years and spent tens
of millions of dollars these are the
people who smeared the Covenant Catholic
kids uh clearly they got a track record
for track record of being wrong but
there are people who just never break
out of those lies how do you how do you
how do you do it especially when we're
talking about for for you you know or
anyone else who's in office you're
showing up and you're like okay that's
not true Nancy the thing you're saying
about Trump didn't happen why do you
believe that and then she votes on
something based on a fabrication they
vote because Justice malet said
something the only thing you can do is
continue to fight and tell the truth I
mean that's that's that's all you have
and I would make the argument I mean
look at the show as an example I got
involved in politics uh a lifetime ago I
was first elected to congress in 1990. I
was 32 years old and
the only way I could ever get the truth
out was to buy an ad
I I the talk radio didn't even exist
Rush Limbaugh was just getting started
back then you everything was whatever
the newspaper or the television said and
there wasn't there weren't cable news
networks even back then so all you had
was the national media and then your
local media and if you had a dissenting
voice you either had to run a campaign
and buy ads or you had to knock on as
many doors as you could so the idea that
that we are powerless to fight against
these lies Europe a case in point where
that simply isn't true the reality is we
have more opportunity to get our point
across today than we've ever had now
they have more opportunities to get
there because there's more media
generally the bigger problem we have is
not that we can't get our message out
it's how do you talk to people that
don't agree with you that's the problem
the problem is you're you're siled
everybody just gets you know uh
information that agrees with their point
of view and they and they discount to
the point of not believing anything that
comes from people that they don't they
don't agree with it's true but it is the
the rule on the left and the exception
on the right there's a decent amount of
people on the right who believe fake
things and they just look for tribal uh
answers but on the left it is it's a way
of life yeah so for instance because I
don't believe in truth I mean so that I
mean let's just get to the bottom line I
believe they agree they they believe in
in they have a relative they have a
relative relativism point of view it's
my truth and and whatever they think is
the truth and and conservatives by and
large not all because we have some I
truth folks on our side too but overall
I think you're right it's the exception
we believe there is a truth there is a
right and wrong there is reason and but
through reason you can come to a a a a a
a conclusion they don't believe that
anymore it's how I feel exactly it comes
back go ahead I was gonna say they don't
believe in truth they believe there is
no truth but Power correct that's it
which actually the roots of it even in
our modern culture today come from
Marxism I mean that is the literal ideal
of Marxism and ultimately one of the
things that marxists do and they've
always done throughout history is if you
can control what people say you can
control what they think if you can
control what they think you control
reality essentially and you're in total
control then this is the ultimate aim of
totalitarianism and ultimately that is
the aim of the modern democratic party
and that's why you see a complete effort
to redefine everything to make words
mean nothing didn't they redefine the
word definition that may have been a
meme uh do you know what the people's
mic is what there's a reference to no
during Occupy Wall Street this probably
predates occupied but this is what my
first I first encountered it
you're not allowed to use electronic
voice amplification in New York so what
we're going to do is when I say
something everyone repeat it back at me
so that everyone can hear
then the speaker stands up and says mic
check everyone yells mic check and then
they'll say something the entire crowd
repeats now anybody knows anything about
cults knows that that's a Colton Colton
doctrination technique I remember their
idiots right and the videos are are
insanely creepy there's one
where I posted on Instagram where
everyone's sitting with their hands up
and there's someone chanting like you
know black lives matter is good and
everyone just repeats it after the
speaker it's like they've and this is
with amplification so we're no longer in
the space where we need to lie and claim
we're just trying to make people sound
louder so you can hear what they have to
say now they have the speakers and
they're still doing the same thing
because making you say something over
and over again and drives it drills it
into your brain
I think we're dealing with a cult and
their counter is projection they say the
right is projecting on us and then it's
like bro you you believe Jessie Smollett
spare me okay well the Trump people are
in the queue cult and I'm like that's
like 10 people okay and in all
seriousness there's maybe a few thousand
maybe tens of thousand but we're talking
about 74 million people who voted for
Trump they don't believe that stuff
these are people who work in you know
Union steel mills or whatever they don't
believe all that crazy nonsense some of
them do those are the ones that Comedy
Central puts on TV but when you go to
the left these are the prominent million
subscriber channels pumping out nonsense
misinformation and lies Rachel Maddow
nearly crying when the revelations that
Trump didn't collude with Russia came
out I mean did you see the video oh yeah
I and I do think that's the fundamental
difference you just nailed it which is
they'll pick the The Fringe on the right
and try to make them mainstream but The
Fringe on the left are the mainstream
politicians the mainstream media figures
the Hollywood figures they're saying
completely insane stuff that if anybody
in the right ever said anything
equivalent to that if a senator Santorum
said something equivalent to that I'm
gonna be a 24 7 News is meltdown yeah
the difference is that when our French
people say French things we condemn our
French people and we walk away from them
and yeah like with their French people
say French things well actually they're
mainstream people say for example I was
gonna say I've learned more about cue
from NPR than I have from any right-wing
person I've ever met in my life I had no
idea the details until I heard NPR give
me a thorough explanation I learned it
from CNN not NPR but yeah same thing
let's let's talk about the convention of
States so you know we've been talking
about first the potential for
international conflict but that leads us
into internal conflict people believing
fake news we've got a problem in the
federal government people aren't feeling
that they're being represented there's a
lot of people who wonder if a Convention
of States was it Article 5 Convention of
states to amend the Constitution I think
yep that's exactly right let me pull up
the story from business this is Business
Insider
Trump tied conservatives are 15 states
away from an unprecedented rewrite is
that you or me I don't know if I don't
know if Trump would call me I thought I
thought you guys were rhinos I mean I'm
surprised to hear that you're now we're
Trump
conservatives so there you go so 15
states are away from an unprecedented
Constitutional Convention now I bring up
this article simply because they're
shocked they're worried there may be
constitutional amendments at the state
level I think it's fantastic so what is
this Con you know is they're they're
freaked out because they think it's a
bad thing we've had people already
saying they're concerned that if you get
uniparty establishment types to have the
power of a Convention of States it's
going to be gutting the Constitution my
view on that one my my calendar before
I'll throw it to you guys is the state
level guys aren't the federal level
establishment rhinos people work at the
state level are voted by voted in by
much smaller uh amounts of people so
when it comes to a Convention of States
you've got state reps state legislators
so these are these are local guys what
what why is that you guys want this what
are your thoughts on is it good or bad
obviously I think first of all one of
the most telling things about that
Business Insider article there's a a
statement of absolute horror that
Congress couldn't control it the
president couldn't control it and the
courts couldn't control it I mean the
central government could not act oh my
God what are we gonna do
absolute horror right so I I literally
saw that article to hit peace against us
and I thought this is fantastic it's
against you it said hippies against you
guys specifically yeah against
convention Estates a group with ties to
Trump's orbit and Corporate America is
leading the push
Trump is like get out of here you guys I
don't even want you here I love it
Corporate America I do occasionally go
to grocery stores owned by corporations
and I mean that's my time to admit it to
my tie to Corporate America I drive a
car that was produced by that's about it
really this is a Grassroots group
they're over 5.2 million people involved
just regular folks all over the country
they're actually in every single state
legislative district in the United
States of America and I understand why
the establishment is terrified of this
and by the way there's plenty of
establishment on the right that is
terrified of this too they don't want us
taking their power away and giving it
back to the people that's the entire
purpose of this the founders intended it
for right now this gets in the
constitution in 1787 Colonel George
Mason from Virginia stands up two days
before the end convention he says this
is terrible we drafted a document
doesn't give the power to the people to
propose amendments but we gave that
power to Congress and he asks are we so
naive that we believe that a government
that becomes attorney will restrain its
own tyranny wow got to give the power to
the people right and in fact it's really
weird in Madison's notes that's where we
know everything that happened from the
convention all it says right there is
nincom Latin abbreviation for no comment
not one guy in that room said George
that's such a stupid idea everybody was
a forehead slap I think they probably
laughed in that moment so they put in
the second Clause of Article 5 saying
someday Federal government's going to
get out of control we're going to count
on you folks in the states to handle it
are they gonna yeah well let me just a
little further that that the if you read
anything about the founding that the
founders were fixated on checks and
balances they wanted to to have each
branch of government check each other
they wanted have the states to be a
check they were concerned about the
aggregation of power into a central
government or particularly because they
came from places where there were Kings
and Emperors they didn't want that power
to all be in one place because they knew
eventually tyranny would be taken over
in the president or leader at the time
would would do that and and so they put
in the United States Senate as a check
and the biggest check was that the
United States Senate was going to be
appointed by the state legislatures yep
and people forget that for the first 140
years of the Republic Washington DC was
a Backwater town with no power
it was yeah it wasn't important do you
know what the largest source of revenue
for the federal government was before
the 17th Amendment which which changed
the way senators were elected we're like
selling booze or something exactly it
was the tax on alcohol it's the reason
the reason we got the income tax
is because of the temperance movement
layer issues the surface the people
choose centers it's way better oh it
sounds way better and they say the the
idea that only the the legislators would
be able to appoint their friends no no
listen people have lost their connection
with their local politics because
there's no skin in the game anymore
right and it not only to the 17th gut
state power to that regard it weakened
Article 5 as well because people aren't
paying attention to their local racism
and the most important too so I I I'll
throw it to you know for one I I when I
first heard him say that I was like what
why would you want that I mean the
initial idea was that better men would
appoint senators and that sounds
pretentious and elitist and then you
think about the math of it the logic and
you're like people need to be focused on
their states
we hear it all the time from members of
Congress they're running for election
and they're like in our town crime is up
X percent when I get to Washington I'm
going to clean this town up and it's
like no you're not you're going to the
federal government to vote on federal
policy right our local elect
representatives are going to fix that
problem but people lost that connection
so I I would before that
um I love the idea of a Convention of
States my one fear is it utopian like
you know because I'll tell you this you
know I'd love to see I'd love to see a
Convention of States happens
the states are all predominantly
conservative which means there's a bunch
of things I like probably a lot of
things I wouldn't agree with being more
moderate but uh gun rights for instance
I'd love to just see them be like hey
you know what we're going to do we're
gonna shoot an amendment and says to
reaffirm the Second Amendment citizens
of this country can keep and bear arms
of any type or accessory or otherwise
there you go we've spelled it out and
then just like stamp
but that's utopian right is would
something like that really happen my
fear is you'll get they'll go in and say
we're going to compromise on the Second
Amendment and say okay we're going to
restrict these things and make sure it's
codified now the the here's the the one
of the important things well there's
several important things number one is
that the convention is being called
pursuant to a resolution that has to be
adopted as you see on that map by by 34
states and the resolution calling the
convention is the governing document of
the convention
and that resolution and Mark can go
through it because he knows it inside
and out better than I do but that
resolution is a re is a resolution that
says three types of amendments are
eligible all three types of amendments
are limiting
amendments amendments that limit the
power and jurisdiction of the federal
government or spending of the federal
government so an amendment offered at
that convention that
compromises as you say on the on on the
Second Amendment and weakens the Second
Amendment would thereby strengthen the
federal government and would be out of
order at the convention what if they
argued that the constitution as a facet
of government is being limited by taking
out some of its protections the the
application the resolutions themselves
specifically say that they're intended
to limit the scope the power and the
jurisdiction of the federal government
so if it's not taking power away from
the federal government and returning to
the people it would be what's called
non-germaine in legal terms and and I
want to address something much more
practical than that it's important that
people understand I hear that people are
afraid of convention convention is a
place to get together have a debate and
make some suggestions now I can tell you
in my entire adult life I've never had
anybody say hey I'd like you go to a
meeting we're going to sit around a
table we're going to make some
suggestions and my response was oh my
God that's so terrifying please don't
have a discussion because what comes out
of convention has to be ratified by 38
States and I'd throw this out to your
people who are watching the podcast
right now that might be worried about
this I've said this to literally
millions of people in the air my
personal email address M meckler
cosaction.com if you're concerned about
this then just in layman's terms send me
the amendment you're worried about and
on the bottom of that list the 38 states
that will ratify it and the answer is
I've offered that to millions of people
I've not received an email because it's
impossible we talk about the Second
Amendment today there are actually 24
States in which you can carry your
handgun in the capital I know I've done
it in most of them there are 14 states
where you can take a loaded AR sling it
across your back and sit in the gallery
and watch the proceedings it takes only
13 states to stop any Amendment are you
telling me we can't get 13 states to
limit or to stop an amendment to to do
anything to the second it makes no sense
I'm I'm I'm for Convention of states for
one simple reason this ain't working
exactly like we we we think we're going
to elect these people Nancy post see she
can't lose she even said she held up a
glass of water and said you put a glass
of water in my or aoc's District you put
a d on it it's going to get elected
that's true yeah something's got to
change something the reality is that we
know where America is headed and it
isn't a pretty place we are seeing more
and more centralization of power we are
seeing let our freedoms being violated
we've seen our culture becoming more and
more woke and the reality is and and
let's just even the more the biggest
reality we're 31 trillion dollars in
debt I mean just a few years ago we were
like six and all of a sudden we're like
30 trillion and and by the way we're
looking at 40 50 at some point this this
house of cards falls apart and we're
sitting here saying well we'll trust
Washington to fix that
does anyone actually believe they will
fix it no no one does so what are you
afraid of are you afraid of a group of
of legislators getting together and and
and offering up proposals because again
you read the Constitutional language the
convention can propose amendments that's
it shall call a convention for proposing
amendments that's the quote from Article
Five so they don't ratify anything they
simply offer up suggestions that go to
the states for ratification and
do I think we'll have dramatic changes
at this convention or proposals that
will uh fundamentally change the
Constitution probably not
the practice is going to be really hard
to get 38 states to ratify anything but
the fact that we would actually call a
Convention of states and have a national
discussion I mean imagine imagine if you
know next week or next month a
convention was being called to by and
having all 50 states send delegates to
propose amendments to the Constitution
everybody would be talking about it'd be
amazing it'd be on the it'd be on the
front page of every paper for for months
we would have groups arguing and forming
to propose amendments and get behind
amendments we'd have actually Civics
taught in our schools about what the
Constitution is what rights actually are
federal rights what rights are state
rights were they better situated
at a time when we are so divided and so
broken having a national conversation
about
who we are and how we'd like to how we'd
like to go forward as a country is
really needed what if you guys could
propose like in your minds the the
Amendments that should be proposed what
do you think yeah I mean I think some of
them are obvious that most people talk
about one you hear all the time is some
form of balanced budget amendment and I
would say that's got to be it's got to
have spending caps and and Taxation caps
tied to it I mean this this is critical
the folks in Washington DC they're never
going to make the hard decisions why
would they they get punished for making
those decisions what oh you want to stop
you want to cut off money to children
and widows and that's how it's always
presented so you put in a structure that
forces them to make the hard decisions I
think that's a no-brainer term limits
for civil servants so this is one of my
favorites and if you look at our
resolution this is really important it
does talk about term limits but it says
term limits for members of Congress and
federal officials and it's exactly
because of what you said because you
don't want to empower the bureaucracy
you don't want to empower their staffers
if you're going to turn Congress
accuracy you better turn Federal
officials and by the way now we know of
this as the Deep state right that was
conspiracy theory stuff A couple of
years ago but so you can turn out the
Deep State when these people are in DC
for 30 years 35 years they have the
power and they have more power than the
politicians and they're unaccountable
and unelected yeah I'll throw a couple
at you one I think actually could pass
and I know uh there are people who might
question that which is to limit the
Supreme Court to nine members uh and you
certainly every Republican would vote
for whatever Republican but I look there
are some Fringe people on the Democratic
side who are for court packing
but the vast majority of Democrats out
there across the country realize that if
we start this game of the Democrats
adding four and then the Republicans
adding it's it's a zoo and and so
putting that in the Constitution would
be if that's the only thing that comes
out of the convention that actually and
it would there's no question that will
come out of the convention if that's the
only thing that happens that would
actually be a good thing in a
stabilizing thing something we can all
sort of agree on and by the way having
something that we can all agree on
that's a big deal is good for a country
every now and then you don't see it
happen very much the other thing I think
too the point you guys made about the 38
States is that these are conservative
states that are that are gearing up
towards this it's not like New York 30
31 of the of the 50 states right now the
legislatures are controlled by
Republicans that's going to go to at
least 32 or 33 this year and maybe more
and with Virginia which is one uh one
house is controlled by Republicans one
is one shortened uh in in the in the in
the Senate uh you could have 34 states
controlled by Republicans and if that
happens we need 34 states to get to uh
to to a resolution pass to have this
convention called we could have this
convention called an in a year or two
but you'll need 38 to ratify it but
again
I'm I'd love to see like I said I'd love
to see the court packing thing and I'd
love to see for example the federal
government should play no role in
primary and secondary education and you
say well that have no chance of passing
I don't know if I'm Connecticut or
California I don't want Donald Trump or
Rick Santorum coming into Washington D.C
telling me how to run my schools any
more than if I'm in Alabama I want Joe
Biden tell me how to run my school so
you'd be surprised remember these are
state legislators not congressmen and
Senators you'd be surprised how many
legislators would say you know what we
don't want the federal government
telling us what to do it so don't be
surprised that there will be more things
that could limit the power of the
federal government that actually could
be adopted even when you need 38 yeah
let me give you a real easy one that
most people don't talk about it's called
a single subject Amendment a lot of
states have this and people are Furious
you get these Omnibus bills they're 2
000 Pages no one has read no one and no
one could read them to be realistic and
honestly if you've ever tried what you
would find is there's so many references
to other statutes and Porsche you can't
nobody can understand them right so a
single subject Amendment says one thing
per bill and the American people if you
ask them it's 99 of the American people
would say yeah absolutely we can ratify
that easily
I wonder
how is it that we get this Omnibus
spending bill it's like 5 000 Pages who
writes that and why do why do people
vote on I mean you've got experience
there uh well every every year the
Congress is supposed to pass 13 bills to
spend spend the money and what happens
is uh that takes a lot of time and it
takes a lot of time on the floor of the
House and Senate and they don't want to
spend all the time talking about those
things so in the end they put it up all
into one bill it's called an Omnibus
Bill because they didn't pass all the 13
they may pass two or three of them but
there's like random weird stuff thrown
in these things it's it it look it is a
process by which you have to get
218 votes in the house and 51 votes in
the Senate and or or more in some cases
60 votes in the Senate so what do you do
your horse trade and you say you want
you know I don't want to vote for this
well how about if I give you this okay
I'll vote for it wow I mean that's the
way things get done it's sort of I don't
know if you're married but sometimes you
got to have to you know give and take a
little bit if you're going to get things
done and that's that's how the process
works we like to talk about guns it's a
really good example of how different
people live different lives in different
terrains right so if you live in the
mountains for instance well we got Bears
out here you know you certainly want to
have some kind of protection for
yourself I don't know how you deal with
an actual bear because you don't need a
big deal
but uh a raccoon or a fox right maybe uh
we've had raccoons out here and you know
you don't want to be chased by one
should it be ravenous or whatever you
know coyotes coyotes for instance the
chickens uh you live in New York City I
get it you don't want a gun you know and
then people are shooting each other fine
I think the Second Amendment you know is
for the entire country including New
York and the people who live there have
the right to defend themselves yep yeah
but the idea we have to bring up is that
the people in New York City who don't
like guns vote for people in West
Virginia which makes no sense I'll give
you a better example is air conditioning
you got the people in the blue areas who
are like you know we don't need air
conditioning it's a luxury and it's bad
for the climate and the people in Miami
are like how dare you because they
couldn't live in Miami they got a statue
the guy who invented air conditioning
down there Texas just secedes they're
like yeah we're out we're out we need it
we can't live without it so you know
that's that's that's not the same as a
weapon but that shows you that if you
live in a cooler climate with less hot
days you're probably thinking to
yourself who needs this stuff that's
well that's fine if we're going to get
rid of air conditioning in the South
we'll get rid of heat in the North
oh yeah exactly you know he burns as
much energy as air conditioning right
there but it's the same same process it
sounds like that's the the problem with
compromise because urine you're in you
know office and someone says I want to
spend x amount of dollars in this place
for this reason you're like well that
doesn't matter that much to me give me
this and I'll do it you you basically
start getting these weird policies that
that's why you have to take the
jurisdiction away from the government
it's you're never gonna look any that's
happened since the beginning of the
Republic they've always been horse
trading that it ha it has to be that way
and and you can make the argument that
it actually reflects the needs of the
different parts of the country because
you horse trade for something that I
want in Alabama that you need in New
York there's nothing inherently wrong
with that what's wrong is that they
shouldn't have the jurisdiction to do it
things that that that are not within the
federal government's purview yeah the
question is how much power do they have
right I mean that's if you take the
power away then you limit the amount of
horse trading that goes on to the the
things that are more fundamental to the
federal and honestly most people then
wouldn't care about what goes on in
Washington DC which is really how it was
always intended to be what you were
supposed to care about were your local
politics what what was the local school
board doing what's your city council or
Township doing those were the things
that were supposed to affect you as a
citizen the founders would be stunned
that we allow so much stuff to happen in
Washington the federal government was
supposed to care of make you know making
sure that we were safe from foreign
threats that there was interstate
commerce that could flow between the two
and that we had some trade policy to
make sure that we you know were able to
trade goods goods and services back and
forth and we've gone Way Beyond and the
answer is to pull it back I want to talk
about the other side of this so uh we
were reading a story from a Business
Insider it's very critical of this
convention of states where you basically
have conservative leaning states are
slowly getting closer and closer to
calling an article 5 convention so just
for those who miss the segment but on
the other side of this you have the more
liberal leaning States getting closer
and closer closer to a a national
popular vote Coalition which would
undermine the Electoral College and in
my opinion literally just be telling the
world like the moment that happens is
hey we want to do a civil war here is
basically what you're saying if you do
this I think it's a terrible idea a
Convention of states is like well
they'll propose some some amendments
maybe they can happen but I mean if you
need 38 states to ratify anyway that
could happen through the Congress anyway
I'd imagine a Convention of States being
called open to conversation under mining
Electoral College through States
agreeing with each other just instantly
ends the Republic electoral process for
for the president
it it fundamentally changes how we elect
a president and and
makes the flyover states
real flyover states they become ignored
because they uh they don't have the they
don't that's not where the votes are the
presidential campaigns will be run in
California Texas Florida and New York
that's where that's where it will be
decided and it's not just that though
and that's by the way every every
president will be beholding to those big
blue population centers because that's
where the people live even in red States
you better realize this yeah so uh West
Virginia for instance yeah when you go
to the cities in West Virginia they're
still more liberal leaning and the
surprising thing is to me you know in
the second most Trump supporting State
you can go to a city and see the rainbow
Flags there's uh areas of Virginia rural
Virginia as well when you're out in the
Farmland when you're out in the rural
areas and the houses are few and far
between what do you see you see Trump
signs everywhere we got one big sign
over here it's a gigantic sign it says
the swamp is 40 miles that way it's
hilarious and then you you go into a
town of 20 30 000 people still the city
and you see the BLM Flags so what's
going to happen then is you got a
politician with only so much money we go
National popular vote it's going to be
even in West Virginia the politicians
are going to be saying things to Pandora
liberals because you got 20 000 votes I
can go here do a rally get all of them
or I can go to Farms come on that's too
difficult it's too far away so this is
just I think this is the inversion of it
of you know what we see the convention
of States this is a move being being
made by the Democrat liberal leaning
states which I think either centralized
power right yeah as Mark said I mean all
you have to understand about the left
it's all about power everything they
want to do everything it the motive
behind it is to accumulate power and
centralize it into the elites who they
believe best know how to run everything
so what do you do man I mean if if
you've got half the country moving
towards this half the country moving
towards a a Convention of States you've
got a pulling away in opposite
directions the culture is already
fractured people have already been
talking about Civil War long before I
ever brought it up I think the
convention of states is actually the
antidote to the to the to the Civil War
I think you're right I think this
country is increasingly divided
increasingly distrustful of the other
side not just distrustful they're about
right hatred of the other side they they
believe that they have uh bad motives
and want to hurt them and harm them that
is that is a that is a a
headed toward very
ugly things and what Mark has been able
to do is take a lot of people who maybe
feel that way not maybe they do feel
that way and channel them into something
that the founders provided as the
emergency escape Clause you know the
problem with national popular vote from
a marketing perspective you said like
the easy thing sells right take away
your vote to vote for your Senator that
sounds bad you're not going to repeal
the 17th Amendment National popular vote
when you say to people what's ridiculous
somebody wins the popular vote for
president and then they're not president
that's a pretty good marketing tool in
my opinion much harder to counter to
explain to people why that doesn't work
so I think it's a very dangerous
movement I agree with Rick I agree with
you I think we are headed towards a
Civil War I think the country is
decoupling where I differ with a lot of
people is I think it's awesome and the
reason I think it's awesome is because
this is how our country has always been
we have some fantasy that we've been
some unified country like right before
the American Revolution when the
colonies hated each other and called
each other blasphemers and were ready to
go to no it was that way after the
revolution we get together and and we
decide we're going to form a government
we hate each other so much we form the
Articles of Confederation gives the
federal government no power because the
colonies and then the states don't trust
each other we come out of that there's a
fantasy we all love each other yes so
much so in the 1860s we have a civil war
and we force a union 80 years later
right right after the Civil War we
really like it yeah exactly everybody
that's when things were calm and
peaceful and it's crazy it's never it
was it uh 1876 was it the election was
decided by a committee yes and so
initiation so we've never actually as a
country liked each other very much
except and this and this is what we we
forget it was really after World War II
correct that's the only time if you look
at America where there was a consensus
and it's because we had just gone
through two uh two world wars and a
great depression and people were just
tired of fighting and wanted
to be at home with their family and
raise children and not work I mean it
was an idyllic time but everyone thinks
oh that was America no no America was
never like this was it a beautiful time
it was a great time you could say a lot
of great things about about the 50s and
60s but it didn't take long for us to
say well you know that look there's
agitating against Injustice that's
always been the American way and by the
way in many cases it's certainly in the
case of the 60s and the Civil Rights
Movement it was a great movement we've
always been a country that never just
wanted to everybody get along we because
we're always agitating for something
better and unfortunately the ideology
behind what's better since the 1960s
since after the Civil Rights Movement
has been destructive because it's been
based on relative Vision socialism
Marxism and trying to bring that to this
country and now it's up to us
to to to fight back this culture war and
and the founders gave us the opportunity
to do it it's about truth yeah so uh
critical race theory for instance you
know I I lie it's it's well it's an
ideology right and it's it's also a lie
it's twisted and uh you know I love when
I get challenged by you know I'll be on
Facebook because I waste time on
Facebook periodically talking about
multiple monitors and I'm reading the
news and I had someone uh post about
critical race Theory and saying
Republicans you know they're crazy and
they don't want you to you know learn
history about racism or whatever
and so I quoted uh I posted saying the
meme was like it was a picture of the
the people getting the milkshakes porn
on them and then I just said something
like you know you using these people for
your political ideology blah blah and
then someone said what is critical race
Theory to me so I said oh you'd love to
know let me tell you because I do know
critical race theory is a derivative of
critical theory Marxist ideology the
idea that there are as an oppressor and
oppressed class Kimberly Crenshaw wrote
in her book because I read this I I read
the chapter outlining the thesis the
basis that Marx did not understand the
the racial tensions that exist in the
United States therefore the idea of uh
class oppression didn't work and you
needed race racial understanding thus a
critical race Theory and then I wanted
to quote Derek Bell who argued for
segregation he I think he he what is it
Plessy versus Ferguson was a separate
but equal he argued in favor of it
saying the overturning of this in in
brown beef and brown b v Board of
Education more mistakes and I'm like
don't come to me trying to use the Civil
Rights Movement to justify your ideology
when your ideology is rooted in
overturning the Civil Rights Movement
but these people don't know that they
don't read these things they never
actually read where critical rights
Theory comes from they follow the lies
from the corporate press and so we're
not up against any any you know there's
the truth
the truth will set you free but these
people don't want to hear it they're in
tribes they get their marching orders
from whatever the TV tells them to do
and they claim that's not them they
claim it's the other side and that's why
it's important for you to speak that's
why important for all of us to go out
and not be afraid what what's happening
in America until recently I give Donald
Trump a lot of credit for this
because he exposed the national media
for the partisans that they were and he
did so by just you know punching them in
the nose and getting them ticked off
enough that they dropped any pretense of
being fair and and and wanting to be
journalists and they've revealed who
they really are all of us have seen it
and we've we look I was in politics for
you know been in politics for 40 years
and for 30 of those years
Republican politicians would stand up to
the media on occasion but it we didn't
we didn't we didn't call them out for
who they were we knew who they were we
understood who that 97 of the Washington
press Corps voted for Democrats but we
always tried to you know the idea was
well you don't get into an argument with
someone who prints uh you know Prince by
zinc by the barrel and so that was the
Cradle of the Republican conservative
movement which is don't fight against
the media because they'll Crush you and
for one who did and got crushed I was
used as an example look you know don't
don't stand up and and and speak the
truth because the the left will crush
you now they can't crush us as much
anymore because of avenues like this and
other avenues and and we have an
obligation to use these Avenues in spite
of the limitations that Facebook and
Twitter and YouTube put on those to
continue to fight that battle and do it
smartly well you were on CNN for a short
while what five years
so what happened with I mean to to be
critical of the media but to be in the
machine I mean
uh you know I'll put it this way he's
like I don't know what I could talk
about I I can talk about it like CNN was
a uh was an interesting I loved working
in CNN because I was generally speaking
the only person in a on a show or on a
panel that had my point of view and I
knew that the vast majority of almost
all of the CNN audience didn't agree
with me and so I I saw an opportunity to
talk to people about what conservatism
was uh it because they didn't hear it
and so and and so I had I had I felt
like I had to be better than everybody
else on the panel and I they could
scream at me but if I scream back at
them then I'm going to lose that
audience out there because I'm what they
portray me as yeah so it made me be
my wife said calmer and and more
thoughtful
no I didn't vary from the I didn't back
away from anything I believed but I
tried to make sure that I was
communicating it's not what you say but
it's what people hear right and so I was
trying to say it in a way that people so
for me it was a great opportunity to to
to make arguments to people and CNN
when they put me on gave me the
opportunity to say whatever I want so I
have no complaints about it I can
complain that they didn't put me on the
shows as much as I would have liked to
have been but that's that's that's the
way it goes having said that I got fired
canceled because I made a comment that
uh the United States of America I was I
was giving a speech to a group of young
uh conservatives uh about the founding
of the country and I made the comment
that we were blessed in this country to
have founding documents where we really
didn't have a country before this
country that unlike France which had
multiple governments and Kings and the
history here in America this was a brand
new country we started from a clean
slate and I said the Native Americans
were uh you know we're here but there
was no country and that they had no they
had no impact on the on the uh on the uh
on the Constitution and the culture and
that got me canceled you they canceled
me I saw a meme that's been going around
and it's uh you know you ever see the
meme where it's like what women would do
with the time machine what men would do
with the time machine so there's a bunch
of them where it's like one of my
favorites is the it's like what a woman
would do with a time machine and the
young woman says I'm your I'm your
granddaughter and the other young woman
says wow from the future then it says
what men would do and there's one of my
favorite is there's a guy with full
tactical gear and he's got guns and
there's like a World War one soldier and
he says grandfather come with me we're
going to Jekyll Island trust me just the
formation of the FED yeah so there was
one I saw where
it's uh they're handing guns to Native
Americans and they're saying take these
because they're coming and they'll
destroy you and destroy your lands and
then all these you know leftists are
like like yeah I just might respond to
them my question is do you know anything
about the Native American tribes and
what it was like here because I'm not in
any way justifying the the history of
colonialism but I think you need to
point out if you went to a Native
American tribe and handed them you know
M16s they would just go and Massacre
their warring tribes this idea that all
the Native Americans were like unified
and it's like oh the evil white settlers
are coming to kill us we'll stop them
it's not not the case it would be like
if you said if we went to Europe and
gave them laser guns and fighter jets
it's like yeah they go to war and they
kill each other whenever you give
weapons to uh you know Advanced Weaponry
to a a society that doesn't have it they
will use it to empower themselves but of
course that's called human nature that
is truth right and reality so when you
talk about the history of the Americas
you had nomadic tribes you had some
tribal governments we did learn from and
adopt some of their principles it's
really it's really amazing history quite
in fact and then you look at like the
Aztec Empire and the brutal human
sacrifices and how they oppressed and
enslaved local tribes and it's like it's
not some utopian world but these people
believe in this woke psychotic narrative
where it's just like whiteness literally
from Europe or whatever they want to
call it is bad and wrong and that means
anyone else is good we're in human
history have there not been warring
people trying to control territory
different groups of people who have read
the Bible I mean you look at the Hebrews
and the and the Philistines and and the
moabites and I mean it's throughout the
course of human history there have been
Wars conquering for land and the idea
that
that that is somehow should should not
have happened in this country that
somehow that America is again it's it's
it's not it's a for me it's a dystopian
view of of of how the world and
throughout history has worked well so
you said a moment ago that you were uh
correct if I'm wrong you were saying you
think Civil War what you're excited for
it is that no I'm excited for the
division and the reason I'm excited for
it is because okay if you go back to the
Constitutional Convention the men in
that convention are screaming and
yelling at each other they're accusing
each other of all kinds of horrible
stuff it's the north versus the South
big States versus small states they're
commercial interests that are fighting
against each other in convention we look
back and we've got some weird fantasy
that these all guys sat around had a
couple of pints of Ale and came up with
this beautiful document the document is
a result of that distrust that dislike
that hatred this is where Federalism is
born because it's a system designed for
people who say look I don't really like
you I don't trust trust you you're going
to infringe on my interest so what we're
going to do is we know there's an
existential threat you've got England
you've got Spain France is actually an
erstwhile Ally they're a threat so we
got a band together for a few limited
things I still don't like you but I'm
going to band together in a federal
government with you that's the solution
for right now because the reality is
look people in the South if you're in
Alabama you don't really like people in
New York generally speaking Yeah you
could travel those places you'll steer
still hear all the same Regional
prejudices if always existed they always
will so this is a chance for us to say
well how could we live together is there
any way we can live together and the
answer is yeah the founders the framers
told us have a federal system where I
say you know what you can do what you
want to do if I don't like it I'm gonna
go live in New York I think the
challenge is I don't think when we talk
about the left and the right the left
having the you know the rule and not the
exception the right is exception not the
rule I don't know if there there's an
acceptable compromise I mean these are
people who to cost
ended up committed property damage
rioting and and murderous acts in 2020
and the politicians supported them
outright I mean Kamala Harris was was
funding their bail 13 Joe Biden staffers
I believe it was 13
contributed to the bail of these
individuals who were committing these
crimes I mean I don't know if there's a
solution even through a Convention of
States because I feel like even if you
get the convention of States you deal
them with the power of the federal
government these people still exist they
still have their their uh tribal culture
and and bloodlust or whatever you want
to call it
so I I feel like
a Convention of states is good to
address the problems of the federal
government but I feel like it would it
would be a catalyst for a lot of these
far-left extremists and their cohorts in
government who are going to lose power
because of it and then it just triggers
conflict it just ignites it I would say
two things number one the most important
reason for conventional States is to
limit the power of the federal
government to force cultural Marxism and
and and and and mark and economic
Marxism on the entire country so if we
can stop them from imposing try to to
generally increase the power of the
federal government to the point where
they can impose that on the rest of the
country which will cause I believe if if
it continues on there will be conflict
there's no question there'll be conflict
uh the uh the alternative is a
Convention of states to propose
amendments that will limit the power of
the federal government or even just
having the convention
think about having the convention and
the states rising up and saying you know
we're going to check you that in of
itself May limit some of what the
federal government attempts to do or the
left tries to do because they know now
there's a viable option for the states
to push back right and it's that it
happened nothing horrible happened maybe
a couple of amendments passed but now
that it's happened once it's a lot
easier to have again the the the the the
the the the idea that we're going to
eliminate the left and and their grab
for power that's not going to happen but
it's going to be isolated in the states
of California and others and we'll see
the destruction that is wrought in those
States as we're seeing it now and so
what are what's happening people are
leaving those States
I want to pull up this story from the
post to millennial
60 of abortion clinics shut down in red
states with pro-life laws after Roe was
overturned so for those that are
adjusting and we've been talking a bit
about the convention of States a couple
things that I that I think are
interesting here is for one I definitely
want to get into uh your guys's thoughts
on abortion but I was I was I was
thinking about this for one this story
actually uh was a meme
is it meme because people were saying if
planned Planned Parenthood claims that
most of the services they provide are
unrelated to abortion why would they
shut down when where every weight was
overturned and maybe there's some like
political point they make but the
mainstream press came out and said the
corporate press shouldn't call it
mainstream said that uh it's actually
not true they're not shutting down it
was just Planned Parenthood was like
moving funds around well now we see that
a large portion actually did shut down
when abortions became illegal so I'm
curious in this regard one obviously
we'll we'll have a you know I want to
discuss your thoughts on this stuff but
I was also thinking in terms of
Convention of States would there is it
considered a limiting of the federal
government to codify restriction on
abortion or the inverse to codify the
restriction on Banning abortions right
because that's what the left has been
arguing for I suppose the the argument
from the left is the government was
restricting its ability to ban this the
argument from the right is the
government was giving itself the
authority over it you see how there's
kind of like both sides are arguing it's
an overreach both sides would be arguing
that their move is a limitation
I'm curious your thoughts on on that or
it's let's just say it's a it's a hard
segue into the abortion topic but you
know yeah I mean I would say generally
speaking if you were to give the federal
government the power to regulate or
allow abortion I mean that's essentially
what Dobb said it's like this is not the
federal government's business this is a
true Federalist decision it said the
Constitution doesn't say anything about
this it belongs to the states so I think
that is the correct constitutional
position and I think any time if if
under our convention you said we're
going to give the federal government
more power to ban abortions I think
you're now expanding Federal power I
think either either way it goes whether
it's pro-life or pro-choice it would be
it would not be eligible under our uh
our rubric and to be clear like I just I
want to give my personal bias I'm
completely anti-abortion me too so here
I am a guy from the right anti-abortion
and I just don't think that that's in
the constitution for the federal
government to deal with and you know
what uh I agree you know
um I like the idea the problem is
I should say the challenge is that
you've got aside that's that's willing
to have the Constitution be amended to
enforce their ideas absolutely whereas
you are willing to compromise and say we
don't like abortion but let the states
decide I've mentioned this quite a bit
this is this is conservatives
compromising on the issue of pro-life
versus pro-choice whereas the left is
arguing every state should have to allow
it the right saying let some decide
let's say decide for themselves so it's
split
this is a this is a real example of why
a Convention of the states having the
discussion of contention in the states
is is important to America because I
think as what I'm seeing polls go on and
people realize that the Supreme Court
decision in Dobbs didn't ban abortion as
the left said it did and that there this
is a decision that the people at the
local level and state level can make
more and more people even folks who are
for abortion being legal are are saying
well okay I'm comfortable with that I'm
comfortable with me having to say and
what these decisions are and that's
really the argument we're making with
Convention of the states is look let's
just let's just not just abortion but a
whole host of other issues that are
really local issues education is a good
example really do we need the federal
government telling us how parents should
educate and and and local schools should
know let the community be able to make
these decisions themselves so we can get
an amendment that says uh no more
Department of Education yeah absolutely
absolutely I mean that's at the very top
of my list and the majority of the
American public agrees with that not
just on the right there's plenty of
people on the left that like hey we want
to educate our own kids our own way if
you live in Texas which is where I'm
from right and people think of it as a
red State well I live just outside of
Austin that's about as blue as it gets
people in Austin want to decide how to
educate their own kids they don't want
the federal government telling them how
to do that yes I absolutely agree I
think um you know to keep in line with
this one of the things we talk about
every so often is that uh to put it
rather I guess crudely
the left is removing themselves from the
future of America through the
sterilization of their children through
abortion
and so when you look at education it's
the one venue they have absolutely I say
this all the time that the left I I
wrote a book
15 years ago now called it takes a
family it was in response to Hillary
Clinton's book it takes a village and
one of the things I realized was
everyone said oh it takes a village it's
an African proverb and I said no it's a
Marxist plan because the left
through their sterilization abortion
they're not having children people on
the left are not having kids so if
they're going to win elections in the
future they have to corrupt your kids
and the way they do that is the village
The Village being why do you think they
want to extend expand daycare why do
they think they want to expand preschool
and kindergarten and send everybody to
government schools for all these things
they want to separate you from your kids
because they want to separate you from
your kids they want to indoctrinate them
into their point of view and they are
and and that's why do you think the
teachers unions the the the Roosevelt
when when the issue issue came up about
unions for uh for federal workers was a
hundred percent against it and and in
fact ultimately and still the case today
Federal unions cannot negotiate wages
and benefits why because they knew that
if if if you give the the uh the rights
of of of workers in a in a government
organization the right to to or organize
and you gave the power to the governor
the people in the government to to to
enhance to reap benefits on them then
the teachers are gonna or the or the
federal employees are gonna
shower money on these folks who make
their decision and you're going to have
corruption and you're going to have
control by the union of the government
exactly what's happened in the schools
exactly where we are and and so the it
is absolutely essential for us to uh you
know to fight this battle
there was an um education weekly poll
that came out just after the 2016
election that found that half of
teachers had voted for Hillary Clinton
but something like 29 30 had voted for
Donald Trump I mean the occupation is
completely partisan you aren't sending
the same people and in part I would
argue that The Homeschool movement has
such legs especially after the uh
coveted pandemic you know if you're
interested in education especially in
your own children's education in your
conservative you're probably willing to
try homeschooling or if that's not true
for especially women who have been told
your career is everything if you have a
kid you've got to get back to work as
soon as possible otherwise you will lose
your identity I mean the system is
biased towards the flexible parents who
are willing to stay involved in their
kids lives
yeah we we have seven children uh we
homeschooled all of our kids uh through
grade school it was the best thing my
wife is a neonatal intensive care nurse
she's a lawyer and uh once we started
having children uh she phased out of of
that work and uh she will tell you that
it was the best investment she's ever
made she we have amazing kids we feel
very very blessed and uh I would just
challenge anybody uh anybody who decided
not to do that and and went to the
workplace show me your portfolio of what
you accomplished in the last 30 years
versus what my wife accomplished in the
last 30 years and I would be you'd be
hard-pressed to outdo what she did this
is the craziest thing is that um
particularly on the left they don't
understand the value of an investment in
creating a human life and it's a really
sad Prospect of
what their lives are going to be like
when they're 70 or 80 years old I I gave
a speech in Hungary at CPAC hungry a few
weeks ago my first thing I said was uh
can any of you tell me the name of your
great great grandparents
can you can you tell me the name of your
great great grandparents great great
great grandparents and the point was
in a very short period of time you're
going to be lost your name my great
grandfather I'm telling you a great
great yeah okay so the reality is in 100
years or less no one's going to know
your name you know you will be gone and
and the only thing you will create in
your life that last forever and and goes
on is creating a human soul I think and
and those children then creating other
human Souls that's that's your legacy
and so many people just are have the
very misplaced priorities there's this
photo I saw I can't remember exactly how
they did it but it was like
a single grandmother and then her kids
her grandkids and her great grandkids
and each of her she had like five kids
who each had like five kids who each had
like five kids and it's just insane how
many the impact the impact remember you
you're having these children and you're
raising and nurturing them and you're
preparing them to do the same to the
Next Generation I mean you you put
yourself into your children and you and
and they can then take what you've given
them and and pour that into their
children and their children I mean it's
Gotta came out of those schools yeah the
key and the point is the left doesn't
want you to do that they want to
convince men and women not to educate
their children not to fight for the
souls or their children to give them to
them and they well they will they will
rightly educate your children what you
got to say to them is hey if you have a
kid they could become a child star and
then you're rich yeah or they can have a
lot of followers on Instagram and that
will make you feel Immortal forever
because as you know when you retire and
you need assistance your Instagram
followers will come take care of you
that's what they're known for check it
out there is going to be some influencer
today they're going to be childless
they're going to be 80 and they're going
to be on Instagram which no one uses
anymore it's going to be like only old
people use everyone everyone's on Insta
talker or something like that and then
WeChat yeah and WeChat and they're gonna
be like I use
muciflex prunes you should get yours
today and then the several several
they'll probably get fifty thousand
dollars per read Because of inflation of
course and then they'll use that to
that'll buy them Mucinex Mucinex they'll
just yeah I would just say take a step
back and recognize that this generation
last few Generations have been sold this
bill of goods are the most unhappy
depressed generation most medicated
generation in the history of the country
and there is a reason for that because
what you have been sold is a lie and you
just need to get back to the truth and
understand what really makes you happy I
mean I really do hold social media
accountable for a lot of this I think it
gives you a false sense of community
it's not that it can't be a great tool
and it's not that it can't be very
powerful but you know that Robert Putnam
who wrote bowling alone talks about this
it's just a complete degradation of
community if at the end of the day you
don't know your neighbors you are not
going to be able to call your many many
Facebook followers to help you if you
have a crisis with your kids in the
middle of the night or if you fall and
need help you need to know the people
that you live near I mean that's the
only way to truly feel fulfilled in life
it's a scary Prospect of what the figure
is going to look like for a lot of
people on the left because they're going
to vote for government to replace family
they've been doing that that is what
they're doing but imagine what it's
going to be like when these Millennials
are all older they're going to be out in
a massive voting block saying the
government should provide for us a young
person to change our diapers or
something like that well I think they're
already saying that and you know when I
travel around the country and I talk to
young people and they look at people our
age they're like hey thanks a lot for
the debt or what did we get for this and
and that's what we've done is we've
spent their future it's pretty
outrageous when you think about it we
self-justify that I say we because of my
age but our generation we're leaving
this incredibly massive debt it means
their taxes are going to go up their
standard of living is going to go down
and if you ask somebody hey are you
willing to do that to their kids you
would say well of course I'm not that's
outrageous it's immoral but that's
precisely what we've been doing and
that's precisely what Democrats are
selling to us today
yeah you know I I I don't want to say
that it's
you know you mentioned your age I'm
assuming you guys are both Boomers is
that your numerous oh the Boomers uh
Boomers
yeah we're bad bad people no it's it's
the corruption in government yeah that
it's like the boomer generation for all
this the the the the Flack they get from
Millennials for like gutting our future
it's like yeah okay okay I'm gonna fight
back on that
my point was that you've got corrupt
Elites in government who are deficit
spending and selling you a false you
know bill of goods and then to blame the
regular working-class American person is
is absurd now the problem is the elitism
that has been selling us out it before
the Boomers there were other people in
government it wasn't the Boomers who
started the federal reason okay I'm
gonna fight back on this because
those people get elected because they've
convinced the American public that
government can solve their problems and
they believe it yeah and so you know
they're not getting they're not doing it
these aren't people who came from outer
space and are opposing this these are
people that you listen to this elected
because they promised you something and
you believed it that's the problem is so
I always say you can point to Washington
say oh it's terrible it's so divided
well now we're seeing you know what the
country's pretty divided and they're
just a reflection of that and the same
thing with this deficit spending they're
a reflection of a country that once
material goods and services and they
don't want to pay for them how many
times do you mean how many things do you
want I don't want to pay that much so
let's just borrow the money and that's
what's going on so you can blame
Washington and I do but that's why a
Grassroots movement like this that
awakens America and has a discussion
about what the consequences of what
we're doing is such an important thing
at this time
I wonder if it's just
just a natural ebb and flow right you
know strong men make good times good
times make weak men you familiar oh yeah
absolutely and maybe there's maybe
there's no real
it's just something that occurs when
things get good you don't have enough
people who are calloused and hardened to
what's going on you're trying to wake up
a ton of people to say support a
Convention of States there's a there's a
good argument about about it but let the
argument happen I suppose why is the
greatest Generation the greatest
generation World War II yeah it was hard
because it was hard yeah yeah I mean
people are made I mean everybody wants
to avoid suffering but suffering is part
of life it's whether you want to suffer
for something that's great and worthy
and last or something that makes you
feel good for the short period of time I
was saying this earlier today that uh
you know people often say like maybe
we're in hell you've heard that I
imagine from some people like maybe
we're actually in hell look how awful
things are and I was like maybe we're
actually in heaven because you know this
this world suits us so well you know it
could just be that we've developed for
the world around us or that we are made
for the world but my my the way I see it
is
suffering there's no happiness without
sadness there is no light without dark
no the the universe is rather perfect in
that it's a great experience and I you
know it's just about how you you you you
you choose to see it I've gone through
some really dark days but I've always
just chosen to be like this is something
that I'll remember and I can always say
I've experienced and learn from I've had
some really bad moments you know like
standing out in a thunderstorm shoes
getting soaking wet car broke down and
I'm laughing like
heck of a story man yeah you know it's
something in life you get to say you've
done I suppose and you rack all these
things up and it just feels you know
whenever I whenever I would find myself
in these really crazy moments obviously
not being having my life threatened like
those obviously are truly horrifying but
I'm saying in like all the frustrations
of a
car dying in the middle of the road
having to get out in the rain
um like those are things that are
supposed to be bad I actually think
those are that's the spice of life you
know like you put you put habanero
peppers in your food it burns but you
like doing it you know what I mean
that's where character comes from yeah I
was gonna say there are uh enthusiastic
enthusia of stoic philosophy who say
like you should take a day and fast and
just so you know that you can get
through you can be without food you can
suffer and recover and it's supposed to
be a reminder that you are always able
to overcome challenges you have to not
be afraid to sort of tackle them it'll
work best though if Government handles
it all for you right I mean I would
never do anything without the
government's consent as you know
so there's the the philosophy of the
left is that man is perfectable that you
can make it through life with no
suffering and that's government's
responsibility it's flawed to the core I
mean the reality is you've just
described some of the best things that
we experience in life come from our
suffering we become if we make it
through we can become better people we
become stronger people we've become more
empathetic people because if we
experience difficult times that we see
other people experiencing
frankly to be blunt this is just how God
designed Us in my opinion you know for
for my career getting started I chose to
go to places where my life was at risk
you know like going to the Ferguson
riots going to Baltimore going to
Ukraine going to Venezuela Venezuela is
probably the scariest had to flee the
country actually and so you know a lot
of people think like you're crazy why
would you take these risks why would you
do it and I'm like for one it's like a
passion it's a drive you want to do it
but I don't want to downplay the
experience of the people who have to
live it being somebody who just
parachutes in but the idea is like we
pursue conflict not in the sense that
we're trying to fight each other some
people do and there's some bad people
but that we're driven by overcoming
challenges and overcoming conflict and
bracing it head-on it gives us passion
it gives us purpose the human desire is
baked in for a quest to go out and Chase
something and do something good and
great and I think we repress that at our
own risk honestly and I was one of the
things I think you were saying in the
quote earlier about when with men with
no chest right if we have a society that
that builds weaklings that builds in
Weak character that we end up with what
we have right now is is really where
we're at you know and I want to say weak
men you know and I want to tie this back
to Convention of states which is and
you're going to have people I'm sure
there are people who are texting it's
too dangerous it's too scary and I would
say
thank God it wasn't you in 1776 really
because you would be the ones like you
know it's pretty risky to go against
England this is the greatest Empire in
the face of the Earth and should we
really take that risk and I just say hey
I'm glad it wasn't you you guys ever
watch the Patriot oh yeah absolutely I
always reference his movies my favorite
movies because what was you know his
character was his name Benjamin a
friend's last name I don't remember he's
saying we can't go to war with with he's
like if you're asking me if we should
have you know if we should be no
taxation without representation of
course if you're asking me if that we
should be in independent nation of
course but if you're asking me to
declare war and to go to war or with
with England then I would say no and
then what happens is kids die right so
you know then he's forced into The Fray
and
um the reality is sometimes you can't
avoid the conflict and trying to just
makes it come faster harder and worse so
I often like to reference the founding
fathers there's that famous meme or
writing about how they swore not only
blood and treasure but the lives of
their families and their sacred honor
and you know there was one founding one
of the founding fathers signers of the
Declaration his wife was kidnapped and
used for a prisoner exchange one had his
son killed several of their homes were
seized by the by the by the by the
British and so that was them so straight
up being like let's do it man screw them
like we're standing up for this it
wasn't as bad as these these memes make
it out to be like all of these people
like no no decent amount of them
suffered and lost they risked everything
and that's the reality of fighting for
something good medalia that was the
elites of society these were every
founder was a was a person who was
accomplished who was wealthy who had uh
was actually doing well under British
Reign and yet they stood for principle
and I just you know ask all of those who
are out there saying oh well we can't do
this because even though it it's what
the founders intended and even though
you know we could uh we could try to do
something positive I you know we're I
don't want to risk that and uh the the
reality is that that the risk is is much
greater to allow Washington to continue
to do to head on this inexorable course
to control the future of our of our
nation than to fight that battle and
yeah you might it might be hard and you
might not win but it's worth the fight
well I want to add in I think it's
important for people to look around with
open eyes and understand where they
stand and one of the things we were
talking about earlier is truth right and
reality and just an acceptance of
reality so if you're out there and
you're thinking well this is way too
risky and there could be a runaway
convention that's the only argument we
hear against it by the way then you
should know who you're standing with and
who you're standing with literally is
George Soros common cause Center on
budget and policy priorities La
razameon.org daily cause Hillary Clinton
all these people actually all these
groups other than Hillary Clinton signed
a press release saying that Convention
of States was horrible over 250 groups
have signed this press race every bad
group on the American left it's the baby
killing Marxist communist American
haters all on one side saying this is
bad you quoted The Business Insider
article this is the left rising up
against us and then you've got a few
folks on the right that have bought into
this and I would ask people like look if
I woke up in the morning and somebody
told me hey you're on the side of of uh
La Raza and Planned Parenthood Etc I
think I must be on the wrong side on
this one so if that's if you've been
sold this bill of goods you need to step
back and look in the mirror and see all
these people standing next to you and
ask yourself well is that really the
side that I'm on let's go to super chats
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and head over to timcast.com become a
member we're going to have the
uncensored after hours show coming up
later tonight we post those around 11
p.m or so let's uh let's read some super
chats all right there's some super jets
I'm not going to read that someone wants
me to read a very offensive super chat
but uh I will read I will read some of
the uh super chats asking questions some
of them rather critical so I hope you
guys are ready yeah all right let's see
do for you
this one just goes right for it all
right Santorum was the first political
figure I learned about he tried to
Outlaw fellatio and sodomy even between
married couples and the last also
supported strict gun control in 2000s
this isn't our guy
were you did you uh support gun control
I don't know about the other one no I
didn't I've never gotten a ratings from
every gun group that's known to known to
man so uh no I mean that's first off
just inaccurate that I supported gun
control because I didn't
um secondly uh I stood for a uh a
constitutional amendment to uh put
marriage in the Constitution as a as a
union between a man and a woman uh that
was uh that was an effort I tried back
in 2004 but I never tried to Outlaw
sodomy or anything else in fact I made
it very very clear that uh just because
something that I consider to be immoral
that doesn't mean that it should be
illegal or the government's role to to
regulate that right on uh so a Siri
designs asks a question as if it was a
present tense but um you you're not in
office so I would ask you right now uh
if you were in office they asked would
you vote to it they asked will you vote
to impeach Biden and advocate for
hearings into fauci and Pfizer my
question is when it comes to Biden and
the Ukraine stuff would you if you were
in office today I guess look I'm
concerned that we are headed in a in a
time when we just every person it gets
impeached if the other party controls
the the legislature that is that is a
again that's not to say that the left
won't continue to do it but I'm not I'm
not a fan of criminalizing politics Joe
Biden has made has been an awful present
he's made some horrible decisions if uh
and and he should be taken out of office
to me that's the way to get rid of
people who are doing bad things but to
put the country through a routine
impeachment of a president every every
two or four years I condemned the left
for doing it I would condemn the right
for doing it if there was a legitimate
reason that there is a national this is
a threat that this President is not able
to do his duty and should be removed
that's to me the principal reason he
can't do his duty and be removed that's
one thing
but we have this but we have elections
that's what we have we have elections
and and that's why terms are only two
years for congress four years for a
president and and if if uh if he's done
something uh again I think nothing
nothing he's nothing he's done to date I
would say are impeachable offenses
they're horribly wrong and and policies
that have hurt America but that that
that should not be the standard for
impeachment so fair point in that well I
believe the quid pro quo stuff with
Ukraine was when he was sitting as vice
president do you think that stuff
shouldn't play a role into his
presidency again that the information is
out there and the American public voted
for him and it we can't continue we
can't continue to go back and again
criminalize political Behavior there
there were legitimate reasons for Joe
Biden to say what he said from a policy
point of view and you can say well there
there was that connection yes but there
was legitimate Reasons from a policy
point of view for him to say what he
said the Ukraine stuff yes there was I
guess the issue was they impeached Trump
for the exact thing even though he
didn't do it I again I'm not the last I
know right okay I'm not going to adopt
their power at any cost and destroy the
Democracy so I can control it I think we
have to stand up and and and be better
than that and you can say well if you
don't play their game you know they're
gonna no if you play their game then we
lose everything
man it's tough I hear you're saying I
absolutely do I I would say I come down
a little bit in between not necessarily
for impeachment but I think Republicans
have to play much harder Hardball and I
think Republicans have been way too soft
and and when the power goes back and
forth and we're just under constant
assault and then the Republicans don't
play some Hardball and response it
encourages so here's here's a point I
would make which is I I agree we should
play hardball but for example you have a
president uh who Donald Trump When
Donald Trump was in office Donald Trump
called for the end of the filibuster in
the Senate
right we just lauded Joe Manson and
Kristen Cinema for saving the Republic
by by not overthrowing the filibuster
but four years before Donald Trump and a
lot of Republicans say yeah get rid of
the filibuster we can't be like them I
agree okay there you yeah you want to
play tough but don't take don't take out
weapons they're going to end up shooting
you in the head yeah yep yep and that's
that's what's being warned of Democrats
right now because the what was Harry
Reid and what was it oh yeah the the
getting rid of the filibuster for
judicial nominations it gave us a court
so be careful what you wish for there we
are a rules-based society and if we say
we can ignore the rules and do what we
want because we have power that's what
the left wants to do that's not what we
do what we do is we stand by the rules
so the question uh I suppose and we'll
move on is just you know irrespective of
any actual circumstances if if somebody
did something that was either
impeachable or illegal in a previous
term
Joe Biden is vice president do you think
that should carry into an impeachment in
the into the presidency no no no I mean
it's supposed to be four things done
during the presidency right and and
right the American public by and large
knew everything that he did I mean
different different spins on things but
the reality is let the public decide
ultimately I get what you're saying and
I think ultimately the problem is more
so down to culture yes in that we have a
corrupt media apparatus it's not
informing people and that there are
people who are willing to vote for this
man even if they did know but let's
we'll move on
all right let's see
uh OMG puppy says the left doesn't want
a Convention of States but if it happens
they will switch gears and take it over
bye by second amendment I don't think
that's that's possible no and that's
what I would ask actually and I laid it
out it's literally impossible a
convention all they do is make
suggestions takes 38 states to ratify
even if they could they can't there are
currently 31 States both houses
controlled by Republicans you're going
to be at 33 34 here in the next cycle or
two it's literally impossible so when
people say something like that it's a
weird kind of fever dream fantasy and I
hear it all the time it drives me insane
because I just want to say reality show
me how that happens and people say well
I can't necessarily show you I just
believe that's going to happen well
that's called leftism by the way that
reality is just what you dream it is
that you don't have to justify it you
don't have to demonstrate it people who
oppose Convention of States it's some
weird fever dream that's been put in
their heads and by the way it's
important they know where it comes from
literally the idea of a runaway
convention comes from Chief Justice
Warren Burger he's the Chief Justice who
gave us Roe versus Wade he was asked a
question about the idea of a convention
when states were starting to propose a
convention to overturn Roe versus Wade
and he said well that's a terrible idea
we might lose our beloved constitution
in a runaway convention he was
protecting Roe versus Wade
I think people need to recognize that
the overall overwhelming majority of
this country is pro-gun as much as the
Democrats at the time of the convention
if this happens if 34 states pass a
resolution to have a Convention of
states to propose amendments to limit
the power of the federal government that
means 34 states will be controlled by
Republicans why because if a state
Philips and is controlled by democrats
they'll repeal the resolution that
passed so you'll never get to 34 unless
you have 34 at the time of the
convention and so if you're saying that
34 states where Republicans are
appointing the delegates to the
convention are going to impose I mean I
just got called a pro an anti-gunner
big and and for what I've never voted
against I've never voted for gun control
in my life yet people are afraid and and
we can't let fear govern us well and I
would add it and to be even more blunt
stop being a tool of the left if you're
saying this stuff you're a tool for the
left and you can know better you can go
to Convention Estates all the arguments
are there at convention estates.com pro
and con read them decide for yourself
stop saying the things that the left has
put in your head that's where it's
coming well I'll agree with people
should do the research and check yes
yeah you should know that I was not up
until a year and a half ago I was not
for conventional States so a year and a
half why what changed your mind uh I
actually read what it did because I was
just told by by some folks 10 years ago
when this first came up it's a terrible
idea runaway convention don't get
anywhere near it and so I just said okay
fine well I was never because this is a
state issue not a federal issue so I
just said you know I'm you know I'm not
I'm not a big fan I you know I'm worried
about it things like until Mark finally
said You know here read about it look at
look at look at the actual research look
at the history look at the Court
decisions and there have been plenty of
Court decisions involved with state with
conventions of states
and it's the biggest no-brainer I mean
it you just you sort of read yourself
into the faith now I'm I'm a uh I'm a
zealot I'm like a reformed smoker when
it comes to this do you get pushback
opinion uh I get pushed back not because
I've changed my opinion I get pushback
because people haven't read the
information don't know the truth and and
go by what some Supreme Court Justice
said 20 years ago let's read some more
we got the uh Super Chat here from the
Jinx he says hey Tim been thinking about
becoming a member for a bit was
wondering if you have ever planned to
expand out any video game content since
you have things like pop culture Christ
and inverted world we are currently in
production on a video game we've shown
it several times I don't think we've
ever said anything it's one of my
favorite projects that we have going on
right now it's really fun but you have
to be super offensive you have to be in
the Tim cast lore like we preview it on
on the Vlog or things like that like
yeah you have to be in the now so he
should become a member yeah yeah yeah
it's um we're wait something we're doing
in conjunction with freedom Tunes
Sheamus Coughlin uh in the style of
Freedom Tunes good fun game so we'll
have more we can have more but there is
a game in development maybe we should
you know announce something about it or
something like that I don't know
let's grab some more Super chats all
right we got a lot of people talking
about uh China Wyatt kaldenberg says Tim
Google this Chinese buyers snap up U.S
oil purchases at widest discounts ever
they are buying timber land Metals
minerals and every resource Wall Street
will sell them that doesn't sound good
no and it's true I mean it's absolutely
going on Farmland is another thing
pieces of land near American military
installation is the idea that we're even
allowing this and you know part of the
reason we allow it is because people are
cowed because if you say well we
shouldn't allow the Chinese to purchase
our land oh well now you're a racist now
you're a xenophobe and the Chinese love
this they're using this against us our
good nature so they'll plant that in for
they plant them absolutely and they look
at it saying oh we know exactly what
their weakness is we know exactly where
to hit them they're going to acute
they're gonna do anything they can to
avoid being called the r word right we
just can't have this yep all right
let's see what we got here
oh
Illuminati confirm 69 says the Chinese
Elite are ethnic Han and China is the
nation state of the Han they pursue
Chinese interests meanwhile U.S Elite is
foreign China is at least a real country
and an economic zone
now what do you think of that do you
agree well first off America he is right
in this respect that America is not an
ethnicity it is a set of values and
ideas that's what makes us who we are
and that's why the left and the threat
that they pose is such a great threat
when they when Barack Obama said he
wants to transform America that's what
he was talking about changing the values
and principles that America was built
upon and uh and that's why this fight is
so important so he's right that America
is not it's not an economic zone but it
is a it is a values and moral uh moral
Zone and the that's that's why unlike
other countries this battle for the soul
of America is in fact real because we're
not in ethnicity we don't have a culture
that's built on on thousands of years of
ethnic history and wouldn't you say that
like China benefits when we're more
divided I think of like the opioid
crisis in fentanyl which is illicitly
produced in China traffic across the
southern border and just further divides
American middle class as well as
cultural Elites war with China and
excuse me there or with us we we have
not decided we're at war with them yet
all right we got Ian Smith he says Nancy
Pelosi like Pelosi likely in Taiwan to
secure tsmc contract tsmc most valuable
semiconductor fabricator Worldwide
Moving to Phoenix Arizona semiconductor
bill passed by U.S last Friday have you
heard that is that true they're moving
there they they have a plant that
they're building there yeah where is
that yeah there's a plant there but uh
obviously they just passed the
semiconductor or they're potentially I
don't know if it's signed yet or
whatever but uh that's that may be part
of it uh but again I don't yeah I think
that's important though to point out
aside from the geopolitical consequences
of what happens in Taiwan that's where
the chips are produced and the Chinese
understand that if they get a
Stranglehold on Taiwan they control all
technology in the world they literally
can shut down virtually anything that
way
Porkins hold it says great to see Rick
and Mark on timcast Trump licens calling
them rhinos chill the F out y'all came
to the grand old party in 2016 and 2020
where individualists and different
opinion and policy not a hive mind like
on the left
man I think that's so important and so I
haven't been involved in politics as
long as Rick I go back to to 20 2009
basically one of the things that's
always driven me crazy about the
conservative movement when we started
the Tea Party Movement all kinds of
people in the Tea Party Movement thought
we're the first conservatives ever to
walk the face of the Earth and they gave
no Credence to no respect to those who
came before them the conservative
movement's been around for a long time
there are a lot of flavors inside of it
and I think we need to respect all of it
I was part of the Republican revolution
in 1994 people I remember the the first
time they got the Congress the contract
with America I mean we uh I was part of
a group called The Gang of seven back in
1991 and 92 and you know we exposed
corruption in the house bank and we
threw out the speaker that I mean I I
was I was the original bomb thrower back
in the day and you know now I'm a rhino
right and because some guys like I said
some guy's been a conservative for 20
minutes
all right let's uh let's get this from
Wagner oliviera says Tim since you like
the freedom caucus I discovered recently
that Ron DeSantis is one of the founding
members of the caucus is that true yeah
that is true and and I love Ron DeSantis
he's actually an endorser of the
convention of States project he's
actually one of the few politicians I've
ever endorsed I generally don't endorse
politicians because they just betray you
and crush your heart Chopper DeSantis
2024. uh me I would say DeSantis what do
you think well number one I endorsed Ron
DeSantis when he first ran for congress
I went down to Florida and did a did a
rally for him and he was in a
competitive primary and I endorsed him
when he ran and uh I thought he was a
strong candidate then and I think he's a
he's been as good a governor as I've
ever seen in in my time in America and
he's to me he's the he's the right blend
of having the right policy prescriptions
he is he is a Maga you know nationalist
conservative populist I wrote a book
back in 2014 called Blue Collar
conservative which Donald Trump would
even tell you is what what he used as a
as a template for his his Maga movement
and did it better than I did when I ran
in 12. and I think DeSantis believes the
same same philosophy uh has the guts to
stand up to the National media he's
shown that repeatedly in Florida and is
not as abrasive or as radioactive as
Donald Trump well I want to add a Nuance
to that which is I you know if I were a
DeSantis or advising him and I don't
know him I don't talk to him but what I
would say is if you end up running
against Trump you don't go after Trump
he should say look Trump was a great
president I admire Donald Trump endorsed
me when I ran for governor we needed
eight years we need eight years of a
good solid conservative president but
what if you got Trump DeSantis then
DeSantis then DeSantis I don't think
it's realistic that's not generally the
way political Cycles work that's a
powerful you know it's hot though
because no I mean like you you're really
hoping like to get yeah the idea that
you're gonna get three consecutive terms
just generally doesn't happen and I also
think especially because of how Trump is
it's just going to pump up the
radioactivity in four years it's gonna
make it much harder forever whoever
follows in his footsteps wants to fire
everybody yeah I like that yeah but the
reality is Trump had it for him to lose
and he lost and there you can say well
they were after him they did all these
things
yeah but obviously he didn't handle them
well because he had handled them well
it's not like
the media didn't go after Republicans I
mean we're really go back I I always
encourage people if they're in
California go to the Reagan Library
there's a whole display there of the how
the media just beat the tar out of
Ronald Reagan they they did they tried
to destroy him and he was able to handle
it and win and Trump fought I agree but
he didn't handle it and win and I want
someone who can handle it and win
all right let's see so um moan I think
pronouncing the right says Tim only goes
hard on the left guess reason why he
can't get any more left guests you need
to gatekeep your people more hard than
those you disagree with one of the
things moan's been asking is that um
arguing what are your thoughts on Iraq
having wmds would you support War uh and
if and if there was war with China how
would you respond to it I would support
Israel doing what I think Israel will
have to do and Saudi Arabia will have to
do which is take out Iran's nuclear
capability at some point because Iran
with a nuclear weapon is an existential
straight threat to the state of Israel I
mean they've been they've been you know
it's one of those things where you hear
the leaders of a country say we're going
to eliminate you we're going to make
sure that you know Israel doesn't it and
then you can't sit there as a small
country like Israel and say well they
didn't really mean it if they have a
nuclear weapon then they can drop a bomb
and do it then then they'll probably
drop a bomb and do it and they'll
survive uh Iran Will Survive it and so
so you have to stop it from happening
well how do you do that I I suppose the
issue is the Israelis could do it I have
no doubt about that would this not
spiral out into a greater internet not
if not if the International Community as
they should stands behind them and says
that they're they're going to support
their ability to maintain to to maintain
their own existence and that's what this
is about yeah going back to Iraq Iraq
was a mistake absolutely obviously a
huge mistake we flipped the balance of
power in the Middle East in a way that's
been very deleterious to just general
World Order and I agree with Rick I mean
I think the biggest problem in the
Middle East right now is that we
throttle Israel and that we do our best
to keep them from doing the things that
they need to do for their own security
and I would argue for the security of
the world and them destabilizing or
taking out the moolahs or the the
Iranians capability is a very it's not
just the Israelis it's the Saudis it's
it's basically the Arab world remember
Iran is not an Arab country it's a
Persian country the it's a Sunni it's a
excuse me
I'm all of a sudden Shia country it's a
Shia Shia Muslim as opposed to Sunni
Muslim there there are it's not just
Israel that wants that does not want
Iran to have a nuclear weapon it is is
the entire most of the Middle East and
it will not be I suspect it will not be
just Israel that will will in the end
stop Iran from getting there what are
your views on entering into a conflict
with China my attitude is and I'll tell
you this too my attitude on Ukraine for
instance is I don't think we should be
involved at all I certainly understand
the history of the region I went over
there and I met a lot of people talking
about you know Ukraine's desires for
entering the EU or or potentially NATO
that came up less but I'm wondering you
know thoughts on Ukraine Russia conflict
and then potential conflict with Taiwan
should the U.S be involved in either of
those so in regard to Ukraine a little
strangely both sides of my family from
Ukraine never felt any particular
connection to Ukraine
if I got to draw the line though and I
first of all no boots on the ground
absolutely no American blood should be
spilled over there if I can use money as
a proxy and we can be killing the
Russian military on the ground without
putting American lives at risk to some
extent I'm in favor of that we're
weakening a geopolitical foe we're
weakening a a NATO foe by spending money
not by spending our lives
with limitations and and part of it for
me also is are we actually there to win
are we actually playing a game where we
we intend to let the ukrainians or help
the ukrainians win if we're not there to
win and this is one of my problems with
conflict in general man when you go into
a war when you're fighting a conflict
the only reason to go into conflict is
to win so what's the exit strategy
what's the end of this thing I've not
heard anything like that and so I think
what we've got is an interminable
conflict that's draining the coffers of
the United States and I think that's bad
in a general sense in regard to China
from my perspective and Rick said this a
bunch of times we are at war with China
we're in a conflict with China are we
looking for a hot war no I mean I don't
think that's modern history the cold war
is really the model but that was
actually a war we were actually at war
with Russia in technological ways in
Espionage ways we're not treating China
as that kind of a foe and that needs to
be our footing all right here's a here's
a hard one and Arco Booth says classic
Republican impotence when the shoe drops
and there's a power grab they make
concessions while the left rallies and
mobilizes
yeah I'm not sure what concessions we're
making I'm not aware of anything yeah
I'm probably in reference to like
impeaching Biden for instance so I I I
know you made your point on this the
view for the impeachment of Bill Clinton
by the way I just say no so
but we're interested in Biden now
but I'll put it this way for a lot of
people who are probably not there's
probably a lot of long time really
staunch conservatives who sought Trump
and they were like to battle and there's
a lot of people that are probably more
in a similar space to me that were like
neutral to Liberal moderate and then we
see the the Democrats just trample over
everything take what they want while
claiming it's the Republicans doing it
and then what happens with Trump is do
you have people begging someone to
please just stand up and say no
and he did yeah and so what people and
DeSantis does it too DeSantis
I think DeSantis Does It Better In some
ways yeah you know like uh when he I
can't remember he's at a press
conference and then you know the Press
asks him something and he just laughs at
him and insults him it was a while ago I
think the difference is though he what
he does is he destroys their underlying
premise he's actually using logic so
instead of just saying you're fake news
and I hate you and what and DeSantis I
just saw his press secretary do this two
days ago somebody was complaining from
Politico saying DeSantis won't deal with
any press That's opposed to him because
he's scared of negative media and he
said we're not scared of negative media
everything you do is negative it's just
you're not relevant we don't care what
you think and I actually think not
caring is a better approach than simply
doing combat with them the reality is
and this is becoming more and more true
every day because of people like you the
New York Times doesn't matter like they
used to matter yeah the problem going
back to the the question the problem is
you can't pick every fight you can't
fight every fight I mean if you're out
there and that's what that what Trump
wasn't able to do he couldn't back down
from everything was a fight and he just
every single day was a fight every day I
mean there wasn't a day that went by
that he wasn't fighting about something
that somebody said and and you need to
pick your battles and so going after A
demented guy who's not going to run for
reelection and spend two years getting
going after a guy uh in in an
impeachment of Joe Biden when he's not
going to run for election he's going to
be gone why are you wasting your time
doing that I mean you just don't pick a
battle that matters more to the
Americans so generally speaking the
battle that I would pick is we need to
go after all of these offenders inside
these administrative agencies we need to
start investigating the agencies gutting
the agencies I'd call no problem going
after Tony Fouch
investigate the heck out of it fauci
should be hauled before Congress and and
I think to to be muscular which is what
the commenter is talking about we ought
to hamstring the entire federal
government that ought to be congress's
approach if the Republicans take power
which I believe they're going to they
need to do everything they can to
hamstring the operations of the
administrative State let's grab uh one
more Super Chat here we got Brian lead
who says I love Rick Santorum his book
it takes a family was the first
political book I ever bought and read
he's a sincere Christian and an honest
man I wanted Rick to become president
oh you're going well
are you going to announce your
presidency right now thank you I don't
think he's related to me so I know
that's really nice thank you all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and share the
share with your friends we're gonna be
heading over to that members only
uncensored after hours show which we'll
go up about 11. you can follow the show
at timcast IRL you can follow me at
timcast Rick you want to shout anything
out
um joints joint conventional States I
mean just go go to go to that website
and and learn about this if you if you
oppose it I I plead with you
do what I did go read the material and
if you still feel the same way fine but
don't don't just take
some meme that you saw that this is you
know runaway convention or a gun read
the facts and then I I think the vast
majority of you do will will end up
joining us yeah two things I would say
number one pick a side I mean we're at
War here in our own country for the
country and frankly you're either with
the marxists and the leftists who are
destroying the country and you're
willing to accede to that or be a tool
for that or fight with the Patriots the
people who are standing and you
mentioned the movie the Patriots stand
up fight because they're coming for you
they're coming for your family and then
last I want to say to the Grassroots
that are out there I know of a lot of
murder fans I've literally received more
texts and emails about being on your
show than anything I've ever done in 12
years of politics I got a lot of advice
like you're going in to see Tim this is
like going into the heart of it it's so
awesome I would say to those people God
bless you guys I mean I love you Rick
and I get to travel the country we meet
Americans have hope there are great
Patriots out there all over the country
there there are a lot of people who are
like you know 10 and why aren't you
challenging them on a rock and all of
these things and I'm just like for one
I think the important thing is if you
guys have a difference of opinion on
foreign policy it's like there's only so
much I can say when I'm like I disagree
and then you say I disagree or like the
abiding thing what are we going to do
just keep talking back and forth where
you say no and I say yes and like we're
not getting anywhere when it comes to
people the people we've had on from the
left it's like they'll say something
factually incorrect and then I'll be
like that's not true that's not a real
thing your opinion can be something on
policy I argue with Sheamus about you
know pro-life and pro-choice and stuff
because I lean more towards traditional
old school approach choice but so we can
have an argument about policy positions
but if you have an opinion I don't agree
with I don't know something to say to
you guys right it's like we disagree
let's let's what else do you think and
look I think you're good you've been
challenging us you've been putting out
the questions where people challenge us
yeah you even said people said he was a
rhino and all these weird bills that he
sponsors so to me to get I mean how do
you get much harder than that those are
the fun ones I mean give you a chance to
you know and I think those are important
I want to entertain those questions
always so we need the good ones too like
people saying your book really helped
them and things like that we need to you
know uh we'll move on Hannah clear want
to shout anything out yeah
um I'm a writer for timcast.com so I
encourage you to go over there and click
on the read tab I'm there five times a
day I'm also on pop culture crisis
tomorrow with Brett and Mary at 3 P.M
Eastern Standard Time you can follow me
on Instagram at handclare.b I just want
to say if anyone has been following the
stuff that's going on Kentucky with the
flooding I really encourage all of you
to take action and find ways to donate
to those communities because it's pretty
devastating right absolutely and a
special thanks to Chris for running the
show today while Lydia's on vacation
thanks for watching all right we're
gonna head over to timcast.com we'll see
you all over there and thanks for
hanging out